with Apple entering the watch market
it's worth taking a look at two things
the current state of play in
smartwatches and whose world gets
upended if Apple's bet pays off
first the lay of the land right now the
SmartWatch world is already populated by
the likes of Samsung LG Sony pebble and
Motorola in some cases these companies
are already working on their second or
third generation of smartwatches but all
of that furious activity hasn't done
much to attract customers yet according
to market researcher IDC the total
number of shipments of all wearables
that includes fitness trackers eyewear
and smart watches amounts to nineteen
point two million units for 2014 that
compares to 301 million shipments of
smartphones for just the second quarter
of 2014 but IVC thinks that market is
going to grow by 2018 the company says
total wearables shipments should reach
112 million units Apple would like to be
driving most of that growth and frankly
why shouldn't it
according to investment banks RBC
Capital Markets a SmartWatch line could
add as much as 11 billion dollars to
Apple's overall revenue that would be a
30% increase over today's numbers now
the second part who's threatened by all
of this well for starters you surely
have to think about some of the fitness
tracking companies out there whether
your jawbone or Fitbit or another
wristband maker the idea that Apple has
made something that does everything your
product can do and more has got to keep
you up at night another concerned
observer in all of this Switzerland or
at least some of its watchmakers global
watch making right now is a sixty-two
billion dollar business might somebody
who wants to spend a few hundred dollars
on a watch be attracted to an Apple
product particularly if that Apple
product comes in a variety of styles
while some of the high-end of Swiss
watchmaking your Patrick Philippe's your
Brigades they would probably be
untouched by the arrival of
new Apple product the mid-range the two
shows the tag foyers the Victorinox ease
could get clobbered